the wreckage of Armenian artillery
strewn across the barren Mountain Scapes
where Armenia and aaban Edge closer to
allout
war fighting talk to match the tensions
across the most heavily militarized
front line in
Europe This Land Is Ours and will remain
as such we will fight for our lands
until the end and we will liberate our
lands from
[Applause]
occupation in the Armenian Capital yavan
The View among volunteers we meet about
the disputed territory of nagoro caraba
is just as Hardline do you think there
is a possibility for compromise for
compromise I mean uh of course there is
a possibility for compromise but this is
our home and we won't give our home
there is if they want a part of our home
there will be no compromise and we go we
will go to the
end these will go to the Army and to the
internally displaced chocolate and
cigarettes for the troops more Basic
Essentials for the
refugees there was a 4-day flare up in
2016 these volunteers have been here for
4 days already though and it looks like
they'll have to stay a lot longer not
least because of turkey's involvement
this time round Anor making it quite
clear that they will stand by aaban
militarily as far as Baku chooses to
go we meet a family fled to yavan from
the town of shushi in nagorno kabak the
children thrilled with the bicycle that
kind-hearted neighbors have given
them elira hakobian fled her home before
in the war in the early 1990s she hopes
she'll be back
soon I put it this way who is the
Turkish government to take away our land
that's our land and we never give them
our land we're always ready ready to
fight and we will always
win France Russia and the United States
called today for an immediate ceasefire
and urged the Waring parties to come to
the table they also raised their
concerns over reports of Syrian
mercenaries brought in by turkey to
support
[Applause]
aan given that the three Minsk countries
USA Russia and France have neglected
this problem for nearly 30 years it is
acceptable that they are now involved in
a search for a ceasefire in the face of
these negative developments that came to
surface in recent
days in the town of maruni two
journalists working for the French
newspaper Leon were badly wounded in an
aabani strike one of them is in critical
condition the aeri is blaming Armenia
for bringing journalists into the
conflict Zone a sign of just how
dangerous things are in what till 5 days
ago a forgotten
conflict Dynam Sky News yavan Armenia